reportage sur l'état des lieux.
Il manque d'eau.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Cette année le mois de mai a
été le plus sec depuis 1942 pour
la grande région de Montréal.
La moyenne des précipitations
est de 81 millimètres. Il est
tombé seulement 12 millimètres.
Résultat : le niveau
de la plupart des cours
d'eau a baissé.
PIERRE DUPUIS
ingénieur hydraulicien
- Il y a des cycles secs,
des cycles humides.
Ce qui est inhabituel, c'est que
le cycle sec, habituellement,
ou la période sèche,
elle a lieu à la fin de l'été.
Cette année, c'est au début.
- Cette sécheresse a aussi
touché le bassin des Grands
Lacs, dont le lac Ontario,
qui se déverse dans
le fleuve Saint-Laurent.
- Donc, le fleuve, à l'heure
actuelle, devrait avoir
autour... devrait avoir environ
8000 mètres cubes seconde.
On est à 6600.
C'est un peu plus bas, mais
c'est pas encore problématique.
- En effet, le niveau du fleuve
Saint-Laurent varie énormément
d'une année à l'autre,
et c'est normal.
Présentement, il est
à 4,8 mètres par rapport
au niveau de la mer.
Le record du plus bas niveau
a été atteint en septembre 2012,
avec 4,2 mètres.
Le débit est contrôlé
par le Conseil international
du lac Ontario et du fleuve
Saint-Laurent pour assurer
le transport maritime.
- Les armateurs, eux,
s'attendent à avoir un certain
niveau dans le fleuve
Saint- Laurent. Pourquoi?
Parce que, si le niveau de l'eau
descend plus bas que le niveau
usuel, alors eux sont obligés
de décharger. Donc, il y a
un coût économique à ça.
- Aucun danger, pour l'instant,
pour les gros navires
commerciaux.
Pour les plaisanciers,
c'est une autre histoire.
- L'arrière du bateau
touchait... était carrément
sur la plage.
- Yves Plante fabrique
des voiles-avirons au Québec.
Aujourd'hui, il doit effectuer
une opération délicate et
déplacer l'un de ses voiliers
plus au large, conséquence
directe du très bas niveau
du fleuve Saint-Laurent.
YVES PLANTE, directeur général,
Jeunes marins urbains
- Normalement, on met à l'ancre
ici deux embarcations.
Et là, on en a une seule et on a
de la difficulté à la placer.
Le niveau de l'eau, on n'est pas
les seuls à avoir...
C'est un sérieux défi.
Nous, on s'en tire pas si mal,
on peut les déplacer
relativement facilement, mais
les autres embarcations plus
lourdes, oui, c'est un problème.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Simon Duplantie est capitaine
depuis plus de 20 ans. Le fleuve
n'a plus de secret pour lui.
SIMON DUPLANTIE, directeur
général, Agence de voile Ohana
- Il y a des endroits où,
normalement, on passe en début
de saison ou que l'année passée
on passait, et présentement
on ne peut plus passer.
- Ce qu'il craint, c'est
que le bas niveau de l'eau
cause des accidents.
- Il y a un très gros engouement
pour les embarcations nautiques.
Il faut juste s'assurer
d'être prudent surtout pour
les nouveaux, de ne pas prendre
de risques et s'assurer que vous
naviguer en territoire connu.
L'erreur du débutant, ça serait
de se laisser distraire
par la beauté de l'océan
ou la beauté du plan d'eau,
et de ne pas regarder sa carte
et de passer tout droit dans
des canaux qui sont balisés,
puis là, justement
d'aller accrocher...
- La Garde côtière canadienne
est aussi préoccupée
par les risques d'accidents
sur les plans d'eau et demande
aux plaisanciers de redoubler
de prudence.
Ici Marie-Michelle Lauzon,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.